family comes first Joe Jonas and sophie
Turner pay tribute to their late dog
with matching tattoos the newlyweds took
to Instagram on Monday to share their
heartbreaking new ink a sweet portrait
of their Alaskan Klee Kai
Waldo Picasso with his tongue out
looking happy as can be
Sophie wrote I miss you Waldo rest in
peace my little baby while Joe shared
rest in peace my little angel I have a
shoulder to cry on Waldo was reportedly
killed by a car last week in New York
City after getting spooked and
reportedly running into the street while
out with the pears dog walker the
tragedy comes just a little over a year
after they welcomed Waldo into their
family the pup was the brother of the
couple's other dog porky who Joe got for
Sophie as a surprise the tragedy comes
just one month after the game of Thrones
star and the sucker singer tied the knot
for the second time in France where
Waldo's brother was a part of the
celebration it's a bit of comfort and
otherwise nerve-racking day the labs and
friends sent their condolences on social
media
sister-in-law Priyanka Chopra commented
a single heart emoji while Rumer Willis
and Jessica Chastain both wrote in part
they're so sorry for the couple's loss
[Music]
you